this is a production of Cornell
University
the topic on my talk today is a USDA
Apple
our cherry germplasm collection I'm only
going to give you a kind of overview of
what we do at Geneva so if you have any
specific question about any on my talk
or you have any question about the
collection please contact me later first
very briefly about someone history for
the national plan germplasm system
President Lincoln established the US
Bureau of Agriculture current a USDA and
also signed two months later signed the
Morrill land-grant College Act in 1862
and then in 1898 the section of CM plan
introduction was established and the
first P I which was cabbage from Russia
was introduced by Niels Henson also at
the same year in 1898 also in 1898 the
federal plan introduction garden which
is the first one which is a current a
subtropical horticultural station was
established in Miami Florida in July the
same year and later in 1904 another
plane reduction station was established
at Chico California in Northern
California later in 1919 two other one Y
in Savannah Georgia and Hawaiian Glen
Maryland was established in 1946 the
research and marketing act allowed to
establishment of for additional regional
plan introduction station that including
the north eastern project we call that a
inai at Geneva New York in June I July
1948 which is become current a vegetable
crop repository in Geneva here just show
you a diagram this diagram is a little
bit old but basically give you some idea
of the center of orange or center of
room for a lot of fruit we consume
current day except some other small
fruit it's native to North American or
North America
otherwise majority of the food that we
consume actually come from utter power
of the war for example apple is actually
should be more central origin this area
is from Central Asia and that's why we
need to conduct exchanges also
exploration trying to collect a lot of
germ plasm from other part of the world
here are some of the Pioneer that
involve was a planned reduction the
first to person on the top is a David
Fairchild and Walter Swing go they are
the two gentlemen in their twenty
actually established sectional plan
introduction in 1898
Neela's Henson is the first plan
Explorer he introduced the first P I
back into the US and famous Frank buyer
spent a lot of year in China doing a lot
of exploration
walsim poppin II he you is actually a
picado playing Explorer spinel Alton in
the Highland on Mexico and Guatemala and
later in Central America and Caribbean
interesting part is he also a spy for
the National Security Agent during the
World War two later in the sixty
professor homo viticulture department UC
Davis collect a lot of variety from from
the Mediterranean region of course dr.
Charlie rooks mr. tomato spent a lot of
time and Andes collecting all of our
tomato germ plasm a lot of those
material actually also have a copy at
Geneva current a here just a diagram
showing some of the location for a lot
of germ plasm stations throughout the
United States you can see we basically
have a lot of different location
unfortunately we used to have a location
Palmer Alaska another station due to the
budget issue was closed down three years
ago some history about how the Geneva
Corner repository came about basically
in 1974 there was a American Society
horticultural science workshop on the
topic of conserving through and not
crop was held in Gulf Ontario Canada in
1974 and later books and the Barton
based on that meeting they describe a
plan for a condom repository then they
argue that I really have a different
needs than those than the common sea
repository therefore from that
discussion and planning in 1983 bill
Cermak who is a supervisor for fun
operation was higher and in Cayman Bora
and a year later in 1984 feel for sign
who was the first curator was also came
on board for the Apple the malleus and
also called Hadi great the Vitis
propagation actually started in 1983 and
the first planting was was in 1986 the
tart cherry collection was originally
housed at the Davis repository in
California but it was moved to Geneva in
1995 for better growing environment in
the USDA our research unit actually
divided into different unit we have two
units at Geneva first one is the plunge
in Edgar resource unit under that we
have a three different project plan the
first one is the secret or the vegetable
crop that combines the corner crop a
poco Hardy grape and tart cherry the
third is actually Appaloosa a breeding
program leading by Gennaro Fazio then
the other research unit is the great
genetic research unit the GTR you like
working on great genetics and also
genomic upgrade here just showing some
the picture of the Como collection
throughout the year this is a view from
1985 where basically it's about two
miles from the Geneva campus this part
of the mccarthy found we are occupied
McCarthy's house and this is about 50
acre you can see that picture taken in
1985 you start some nursery operation
over there 2022 year later this so you
can see at the same location
but just from opposite direction the
picture was taken we basically have a
lot of great and touchy area all the way
in the back and also a lot of Apple the
slide below just showing a lot of
different picture diversity of material
for the malleus we have in our
collection and also some other virus and
heartier they just have a gorgeous color
during the fall season the mission of
the Cologne repository basically
throughout the entire system basically a
four basic mission that's a similar
mission for all the repository firstly
is trying to acquire seconds trying to
preserve and the third is trying to
characterize and the force trying to
distribute all the germplasm we have but
each your posture is a little bit
different for our acquisition we
basically we trying to get materials to
exchanges and also expiration basing on
the worldwide basis for our preservation
purpose we have a fuel collection of
trees and also we have a co storage of a
seat most of our wild contraption plants
and seeds also we have we use acquired
preservation of dormant bar wood at the
USDA National Center for genetic
resources preservation unit for column
Corrado from here I will call them the
for column and also for characterization
will use morphological methods or
genetic muscle trying to study order a
session we have and all the information
from our study basically our store at
the germplasm resources information neck
war database we call that grin a new
version of the grinning should be come
on war this year sometime it's called
green global supposed to have a better
function but so quite a learning curve
trying to change into the new system for
distribution purpose that's the major
difference between the clonal repository
versus the Cu repository basically our
main distribution material at a dormant
bubble but we'll also distribute some
about wood but for research purpose we
also distribute pollen through
flower fruit see leaf and also a lot of
DNA example in recent year basically
free to all the stakeholder and
researcher boasting in United States and
also worldwide also and not a very
important function of the distribution
is trying to increase the public
awareness of the value of the genetic
resources we preserve on the ear early
on basically as the establishment of the
collection because locations at Geneva
so for the malleus collection basically
we just knock on the door of dr. Roger
way that was the Apple sign breeder at
that time we got all the donation from
all the Geneva Apple breeding program
basically been going on for over a
hundred years at that time got a lot of
material from dr. Roger way at the same
time but we also get a lot of material
for other breeding program in the United
States such as a PR a program that's
them for the Apple breeding program
among the three campus Purdue University
backers and also University of Illinois
will also get a lot of material for
other campus and also from agricultural
Canada will also get material from
England national collection at the long
Ashton research station and also
material found several different other
countries for the widest collection
basically we started by donation from
the also from the Cornell great breeding
program at that time was Qatar Bush
right who is still in charge of the
program well also get some additional
material from UC Davis University of
Minnesota South Dakota and several other
places today I only have time to talk
about more about the malleus while germ
plasm material here is a diagram kind of
map showing worldwide where the mallow
species the deuce review as you can see
there are four different species in
North America there's two species in
Europe there's Patras malice ambassadors
or malice Florentina there are two while
malice material in central asia the
malice or intolerance and also sebastião
and as you can see in asia basically
most in
China also some in Japan and other
places marriages have more than probably
close to 40 to 50 different species and
hybrid species over there basically in
general that succumb sense content
consensus that malice actually
originated from Central and southwestern
China and then throughout history
expected especially through the Silk
Road material actually able to reach
Central Asia eventually went to Europe
and the how the material came to North
America actually was belief in the
ancient time during the during the Ice
Age actually layers the ancient land
bridge between the North America and
Asia so the material actually came the
earth directly earth the other direction
came to North America and common modern
Apple we consume is malice domestic ADA
it's a diploid species with satyr
chromosome 34 it is strongly believed
that the origin of Martin Apple actually
came from mother Melissa BCI there's
also some parentage in bhavish maybe
orang talus maybe sounds of estrus the
the question still being debated the
next phase of the malleus collection at
Geneva was I consider it was expansion
phase of the collection especially
through a lot of exploration activity so
on the from the lay eighty into the 90s
the first exploration was professor
Whedon of Cornell University he went to
the west coast of North America to
collect a lot of malice of busca in 1987
later the graduate student Elizabeth
Dickinson for her CSIS work he could she
collect a lot of material in eastern us
also in the Midwest three different
species angustifolia corneria and no
ionises from 1989
professor herb Alban Co once again
together was Elizabeth Dickinson and
also was the curator fell for slime
they went to Central Asia for different
country to collide malice of sei for
different time then in 1997 professor l1
code together fill force line they went
to collect seven different mal species
in China in the southwest China the
Sichuan province later in 2001 gabelle
from Germany went to the same place to
collect similar material there were
extensive exchange material between the
two expiration in 1998 feel force line
together was Professor Amy Arizona from
Michigan State University they went to
Russia to collect a lot of material
including malice Oren tell us also some
other materials such as tart cherry and
some other cherry material in 1999
professor L window together with Theo
force line they went to Turkey to
collect Melissa Warren tell us later
into in 2001 and later Joseph postman
from Corvallis repository went to
Armenia and now Georgia collect a lot of
different species including malice or
and tell us again the malice of sei
expiration in Central Asia has a very
long history a lot of Russian scientists
they studied a while malice which
important material in their region as
early as I can find out was 1796 all the
way into the 1900s the famous plant
geneticist Niko's Ivanhoe Pavlov of
Russia he first explored the wild apple
force in Central Asia basically in 1929
and the in knighting also 1929 Westover
who was a planning Explorer was sent by
USDA to alma mater Almaty Kazakhstan
translation means the father of the
apple also in 1929 met up with Buffalo
and explore the material over there and
in the 1990s
professor den glove of Kazakhstan
Academy of Science with his colleague
they explore all the wild mouse germ
plasm material in in Kazakhstan from the
1950 all the way into early 2000 there
was an extensive review was written in
2003 here's a picture from 1929 this is
what's over who came from USDA this is a
vlog and they met up in in alma mater
basically in Kazakhstan looking around
their mouths sebacio material in their
region and then basically 60 years later
not a group all USDA scientists from
Geneva went there to collect the
material also something interesting and
dig up a little bit Pablo actually came
to Jeanne came to Ithaca in 1932 for the
6th international congress of geneticist
genetics he was the vice president for
the society at that time there's
basically who is who in genetics both
animal and plant genetics were all in
that meeting including Barbara
McClintock also in that trip he also
went to Geneva he actually presented two
painting of Wow Apple from Casa Stan and
quizzes 10 to Professor Willington of
Experimental Station also in 1932 these
two painting actually still being to
preserve at the library in in Geneva I
just wonder anybody recognize the
building on campus maybe still there
maybe not so quickly I want to make a
pitch why do we need to collect also
preserve while germ plasm material from
the wild because a lot of what you're
imposing they're also negative habitat a
loss due to agricultural development
also are also changes in agriculture
change practices also a lot of urban
development issue a lot of animal
grazing environmental decoration is
serious issue such as the soil erosion
reduction in water supply and quality of
course the climate changes such a green
housing
and there's a vacation also a lot of one
plant material also is being threatened
due to new paths and diseases also a lot
of tiles so invasive specie into the
native habitat also a lot of time plant
biodiversity also being reduced because
agricultural intensification also
agricultural commodities ation for
example for the worldwide avocados tray
basically 95% of the trade just rely on
single variety the Hass avocado similar
for when you go to most of the
supermarket outside in New York you
probably only find about you love and
apple variety you accompany Sita in the
supermarket chain from the oh excuse me
gem from the Chinese Academy of Science
they did a survey in 2009 they basically
compare the native range of mallow
silver CI in Shenzhen China compared
with the survey was down all the way
back in 1959 basically they found out in
comparison between the two in that in
the time front of 50 years 80 percent of
the native habitat of mallow silver see
I was lost due to agriculture
development
animal grazing a lot of over harvesting
of the wild fruit also a lot of top work
of the native species into modern
variety and also a new apple insect
problem in that region
here's picture showing this insect able
to attack the mouth of a CI in the wild
population and also this is a picture
from the apple expiration all the way to
the left to the right to the left when
they did our exploration in Kazakhstan
they actually see a lot of sheep grazing
in the wild apple force over there the
picture in the middle is not Apple but
our countries and for Morocco you can
see the sheep really like the Argan tree
over there just trying to make a point
here okay here is the matter
showing the planet exploration of
malaria in Central Asia by the plan
genetic research unit in the late 1980
into the 90s basically there are 12
major site most of them actually in
Kazakhstan but there's also saw site in
Kazakhstan was a Pakistan also teaches
the can hear is actually China this is
actually Shin Jung area the survey did
was about native habitat was actually
right here in this region I here's a
summary about tremendous amount work on
the exploration for malice over CI
basically there were four trip together
12 major site and based on the phenotype
they observe in the field they actually
select 44 they call malice / CI elite
they got the bug would and to bring back
to the United States they also collect
over 894 see a session on malice of Asia
from the wire that including basically
over 120,000 seized together and over
30,000 of those see was actually a
distribute to all the researcher
worldwide and about certain over 39,000
of the see actually stooping store at
the for column and over 50,000 of those
seeds actually store at Geneva in the
last couple of years we also have a
collect over 50,000 open pollinated
seeds from malice of Asia seeding block
at Geneva we call this bount ania desire
sea for routine distribution a lot of
you probably read a book by Michael
Pollan bount on your desire and we got
actually very routine request from the
reader because in the book mentioned
fill force line is willing to give out
the sea so we're constantly actually get
inquiry about malice overseer seeds and
that's the see we don't give out see
from here the original see from the wild
collection will actually give out the
OPC so for the routine distribution to
the stakeholder in the last few year
will actually see a increase
a lot of inquiry actually from European
country England Germany friends most
reason was actually from Finland here
your show is on the picture from the
exploration back in the 1990s
they basically throughout the several
explorations sometime they went back to
the same location at different year to
collect the material professor Tenga law
is the major cooperating cooperator for
all the exploration he actually came to
Geneva in 1992 and then the team went
back in 93 95 and 96 this is Elizabeth
Dickinson at that time she already
graduated but she came back to join
their exploration some time they also
found very nice phenotype in the wild
and they would collect above would they
call that mouse-over CI elite bring back
to the United States a lot of places
they went to actually is really remote
therefore the only way they can get to
is actually to helicopter right here is
on the picture from the 1997 exploration
in Sudan China before the expiration
professor Lee who was from the Southwest
Agricultural University he was the
leading authority on while Mallos
material in China he came to visit in
Geneva in 1996 then a team from Geneva
when there in 1997 professor Elwin Co
over there every exploration is a little
bit different once things stand out in
that particular exploration was there
was agreement the American were not
allowed to collect a few in the wild
directly only in the Chinese scientists
allowed to collect the fruit from the
trees then American able to participate
in processing the material the location
they collect the food was actually next
border to Tibet so it's a very high
altitude so you can see professor elenco
trying to walk up the hill to look at
the yaks
that's a elevation about four thousand
meter
that's over 12,000 feet here's another
picture from the 1999 exploration in
Turkey basically you have to do all kind
of thing when you're under exploration
trip some of them are found here
basically the route they took in Turkey
they start with the city in Izmir near
GNC they first they went up north
comfortable location and then he double
back once again to the north coming back
to zero I mentioned some time we collect
a bowl from the Wow and to bring that
material back to the US basically for
importation of a mouse germ plasm the
bowel material all the material need to
go through from foreign country need to
go through the USDA Avis quarantine
process before the material can come to
Geneva
every year we basically we see between
10 to 20-year session from Avis every
year in recent years on the material we
got from Avis that including malice
silver CI elite from the expiration also
some of the cider apple from northern
Spain that was introduced by Professor
Ian merwin also a lot of different
variety from different country you can
see basically from all over the world
sometime most a session when it goes
through the Avis quarantine process they
take about a few years but there are
some extreme cases especially this case
while the malice of Asia you leave from
Casa Stan was collected in 1996
Exploration trip he only released by
Avis to us last year after 16 year in
the quarantine that just provisional
release so we have the way for
additional 2 to 3 year before its
permanent release to the public so wine
sauce salad non pop we will take between
18 to 19 years before this material can
be released to the public
sometime baby just have some disease
issues that they need they need to clean
up again go through thermotherapy and
the re-indexing sometimes just take some
time some material very difficult now I
want to squeak switchgear talking about
the preservation of the control
collection at Geneva basically all the
variety and the species we have we
preserve them as the life tree in the
field most of them for the malleus and
prunus each of the session we have one
mature trees we start with two tree but
in general after several year old one
trees for the Vitis each other session
where has to mature fine in the field
for the wild malice and the vibration
applause and all the while see
collection from the Wow
we stolen store them at minus 20 Co room
we have one co room in Geneva also one
in for : a lot of doormen bar wood for
the mallas also the poona's they are
under a long-term backup storage using
choir preservation basically store them
in liquid nitrogen for column Colorado
we also have a black material in our
collection we call this the malleus core
collection that including 258 accession
that's including majority of the common
malice current name apple variety but
also other material from 42 other
species and species hybrid i'll do well
rubio here get some water
for the collection we have in Geneva we
have over a thousand accession total for
the malleus collection we have over six
thousand six hundred by including over a
5,000 feel a session also over a 1,500
see a session in the field we have
several different block we have the beam
I block that's the malleus core
collection well so I have to order
larger block the m7 and the Eastman
block that's all the material would
consider a part of our permanent
collection well also have a k1 block
that's the Casas de amalah servicios
heating block they are on their own
roots it's different from the material
in the three other block they are
actually I'm talking you stock before
all the while material they actually on
their own roots on root system well so I
have another block
we call that w3 block actually a several
different wild Mallos material they come
from Mina China Georgia Kazakhstan
Russia and Turkey well also a one block
of material that including five
different f1 population for a cross
between gala apple variety costs with
five different model silver CI all these
file servers here they actually been
shown to have a different disease
resistant so we consider this more like
a pre breeding population how can use
for mapping population for different
purpose for our permanent collection in
the field every single tree in the field
and every single buy in the field we
have a tag associated with each trees
basically will tell you which row and
trees and what's the P I number
what's the species number also the
variety Cove for the ceiling black
material we usually have a tag for every
ten trees or so here to show you some of
the picture from the Mallos survey she I
while collection while species
collection this is a picture from 2004
poster w3 block and also the K one block
over here
in 2004 here is a similar view
you in 2007 three year later this is a
model server CI of different species
here is all the malice of sei from
Kazakhstan a little bit wild Vytas
different wall species on the corner
there here's the view from the Casas
time k1 block in 2012 last year because
they are on their own route they are not
on dwarfing new stock the material
basically are now over 20 feet high
here's a picture of Theo first line
first curator together a professor her
Bronco looking at massive aja material
in the field they spend a lot of time on
those material here's how the pictures
showing some the interest of interesting
stuff we have in our collection for
example we have some of the large food
it Mallos or IntelliJ it could be hybrid
we're not hundred percent sure this
material they are very large food so
there have a some ornamental potential
we also have a some material called
malice transitoria they also from China
they are very dwarf material also very
spreading very different from most of
the wild species this is why the malice
hybrid material called butterball is a
beautiful ornamental material it tastes
terrible though we also have a small
mouse nursery we use for our propagation
purpose purpose in our collection
basically this show you a very standard
or malice material in our permanent
collection we planned over a 150 new
accession last year we also have a small
stew before rooster propagation here's a
very interesting material it's a very
thorny juvenile material from the wild
malice who piensas from China you can
see all the phony material usually you
will never see that in commercial apple
this thing's can puncture to the tire
basically
for the widest collection we have
basically most of material we have they
are wild species also a lot of species
hybrid that means between invite virus
whenever are crossed with different wild
species therefore they have a code
tolerance able to stand the weather in
Geneva
most of the virus would never our
material that's the common one grave
table grab and also over some reason
grave those are all housed at Davis
repository because the weather is better
over there
we have over 1300 a session in the field
and about over a DC or session in the
coal storage here just another few of
our basically main virus collection in
the field with all the models collection
in the background here is also another
material we have in our collection is
the virus hybrid it's a seedless
material or the best tasting material we
have in the field usually by another
season it just disappeared here's
another interesting material it's a wild
species actually from China virus Spezia
PC Zaki Sakai this material is actually
very unique leaf most morphology is a
very deep web material that's only in
two species among over 60 species
actually have this type of morphology
for tertiary collections actually
relative small collections basically
tertiary is a diploid species actually
is is a hyper material from sweet cherry
crossed with some wild tetraploid tetra
point material for example that because
the poona's foods cooked food cosas we
have 130 sessions in total tart cherry
is actually a very small industry only
40 million dollars in the u.s. compared
with the grape industry is over 3
million an apple industry is over sorry
2 billion 3 billion and to bein dollar
in the u.s. most of tertiary actually
originally found Central in the Eastern
Europe and also from Russia
majority of the torch area session we
have actually came from the Michigan
State or Cherry breeding program that's
in charge by dr. Amy Arizona we've done
a lot of characterization for the
communication you know we have basically
all the session P I number or the
species number species name the varietal
name the general description of the
material the source history the pedigree
if there's available also a lot of
digital imaging actually all store at
the Gwynn database will also carry a lot
of phenotypic also genetic
characterization also some other work
such as a chemical composition the
ploidy measurement disease resistant
grows habit morphological trade and the
phenology tray some of the description
about the production also my cassava
marker some of the information we have
or story the Gooden database in the
future hopefully we'll have more GPS
information the genotype by sequencing
marker data also more food quality data
also the sequencing data in the future
all the information basically is
searchable at a growing database website
for the want to talk about a lot more
about the wild malice material a lot of
evaluation we have done in the last 20
years tremendous amount of disease
evaluation work has been done in the
last 20 year evaluate against different
fire blight scab the bloom o
post-harvest decay also a lot of work on
mapping of resistant genes in the from
the wild sources also a lot of work on
draw of resistant evaluation also cold
hardiness also a lot of genetic
diversity study population study also
using the genetic marker trying to
determine the core collection also using
genetic marker trying to identify
interspace a hybrid also duplicate in
our collection we also have a lot of I
mentioned before some of the mapping
population
that could be used for mapping different
kind of tray you want to give you one
specific example about diseases and
evaluation against bloom oh this is work
between the appellation for your full
research station of USDA at the
kearneysville West Virginia together
with researcher in volcanic center and
the PG are you this particular accession
actually is being shown to be resistant
against a bloom oh and they came from
Kazakhstan in 2011 and 2012 we collect
fruit from 101 individual from this F 1
mapping population then way in naka a
the fruit with penicillin expansion and
then we measure the lesion size seven
days sometimes five to seven day after
the inoculation there is a huge
environmental difference from between
2001 and 2012 but this is reading across
the year actually a highly correlated
the QDR mapping for the bloomer
resistant actually being mapped or
resistant to linkage group number four
here just picture showing a picture
we're collecting the fruit last year in
the field for the inoculation experiment
here to show an example of eleven fruit
from two one susceptible and the one
resistance progeny you can see basically
after a five to seven day after
inoculation are there significant
difference in the links inside between
the susceptible material versus
resistant material we also use a
different genetic marker in this
particular example we use nine micro
siloam marker to study over 1,900 miles
of session we have in our collection
we're able to identify 238 Malus
domestica de and also ten other melosa
session they actually share the same
genotype
based on my SSR marker with at least one
other Malus domestica de accession in
our collection once we find anything
with a similar genetic profile we're
also trying to look into the through
image trying to confirm the genetic
study result in this case we're able to
identify total of 23 spore family that
including 100 for a session in the
collection also there's some mistake we
identify also some duplicate were able
to identify from this study we also
carry a lot of holy culture and through
qualy trade evaluation in the early year
our unit actually devote a lot of effort
into choir preservation method
development for the malleus and the
Pumas and also together was for Talon
where they did a lot of study on
long-term survival ray of the
cryopreservation bond material also in
the last couple years we focus along
digital image are different the fruit
the leaf and flower we upload a lot of
image into the grant database we also in
bow is a polyphenolic and also
antioxidant capacity study of the virus
also we're working on the malleus and
the tertiary right now also juice
quality and some specific sample like a
ref wash apple and also through
obsession array of some of the mallow
secession we have here just show you a
different digital image we have four
different material in our collection
sometimes we still have some shadow
we're trying to improve the quality of
the photo in the near future here's just
another example of genetic study of a
ref flash apple apple in our collection
this scene study including over 100 of
session basically they have different
kind of red flash you can see for the
different pattern of red flash they have
some some of the Refresh actually
localized in the calyx area some of them
actually associate with a vascular
bundle some of them just through our
entire court
but now including the core some of them
just focus on the core region and some
of them is here actually throughout
entire entire fruit so there's a lot of
different color different pattern also
different intensity among different
recession we also look at trying to use
in PCR trying to identify the mid 10
which is transcription promoter that
previously has been mapped to linkage
linkage group number 9 that's strongly
associated with a refresh through among
all the genotype but this particular
promoter is not neither sufficient nor
required for all refresh in all the
genotype expression also nearly all the
refresh material were able to test it
actually all could be traced back
probably a single variety nowasky ana
actually is a while potentially probably
a while material of amalah service here
from Central Asia so all the refresh
available right now it's actually aku
probably traced back to this single
variety last year will also upload a lot
of ploidy information based on flow
cytometry also some of the information
based on historian formation available
from the grid we upload 682 malice
domestic ada and malice hybrid Prodi
information into the gun that including
554 deploy material 17 chimeric 91 trip
boy and 20 tetraploid we also have flow
cytometry information for over 664 while
I'm Alistair session from 53 different
species the ploidy is a little bit more
different some of them they have
deployed triploid pen tetraploid all the
way into a pen deployed within the same
species also we basically we have
microsatellite markers data for
basically all the permanent session we
have in our collection so in principle
we should be able to infer the poi D
level from the SSR marker in the future
since last year we also initiate the
Mallos genotype by sequencing effort for
malice collection in this study we
including over 1950 material from our
collection in the study that's including
over 15 14 hundred mouths domestic ADA a
lot of different while mallow species
are including in the study will use two
enzyme for restriction we have 21 play
in total and were just in the beginning
stage of the data analysis for each play
we have we're able to obtain between 100
to 100 million medians goo ray per play
so basically we doing a lot of
sequencing information from this study
the in some of the initial analysis we
done we using Golden Delicious genome as
a reference genome for comparison in the
analysis in that particular study
comparison about 40 percent of the
sequence actually Cunha beach map back
to the Golden Delicious genome actually
40 percent of the sequence we identify
upon a GPS study actually never being
known before also in the future we're
trying to make comparison without any
reference genome so we can we're not
going to create any bias against
especially the one malice material
hopefully in the future we can use the
data trying to study a lot of different
question domestication issues still
there's some debate over there the
breeding history gene flow the evolution
also gene trade association I hope
something we can do in the future and
also other issue relate to the mouse
genome next time to switch gear a little
bit talking about distribution for the
corner collection every year we update
our catalog for Apple grape and tour
cherry that's available online basically
all the distribution or free of charge
to the
stakeholder here's a summary table of
some of the number of sample we
distribute in the last ten year as you
can see back in 2007 and 2008 in
combined with distribute over 11,000
sample in those two years in the last
two year would distribute over 9,000
material per year in the last two season
so that's a lot of work a lot of
material here just a picture showing you
were collecting doormen Bellwood from
the mallow service yes healing from
Kazakhstan for a drought-resistant study
were cooperating with this is about
three weeks ago believe me it was very
cold in the field as I mentioned earlier
before one of another purpose for the
distribution I see is actually trying to
promote the value of the germplasm
material we have in our collection
therefore we carry out a lot of outreach
education event also a lot of - coming
to a Conal collection basically during
the springtime the summer time also in
the fall season so far not too many
people come in the winter time every
year for example the print plant
breeding courses it will come to our
collection in the fall they will come to
Geneva I sing when they come to our
collection they probably have the best
time they are all very happy they carry
our food back - so they're all very
happy to come to the collection last
year also the summer Scholar student at
the station also came to look at the
collection were able to have dr. Bronco
actually talk with students about all
his exploration experience we also carry
a lot of trim paws on exchanges and also
visit with other gene banks throughout
the war for example this missing
eun-young her and she's the great
curator and also molecular geneticist
for the south korean gene bank she spent
about three months with us last year
she's back in South Korea in the future
hopefully we're going to start
exchanging material it
especially the wild virus material
between the two to genebank
here's kind of in the summary basically
the shorten go we have for the criminal
collection in the next couple of years
first of all we'd like to continue
digital imaging of the collection we can
always take in more photo also we're
trying to finish the evaluation of virus
phenology you already have two year data
we're going to do that for additional
two years also we're going to start the
malleus phenology evaluation hopefully
for the next three years we are
continuing on on the food quality also
in nutritional evaluation for the
malleus and tertiary the work we saw
started since last year we're also going
to carry out a gap analysis for the
malleus also vytas germ plasm material
using different geo referencing data the
climate data also genomic data wings
available once we are able to finish the
gap analysis in our collection we intend
trying to begin collection for more
systematically for the north american by
this material which we think we release
you focus on for the next couple of
years also potentially you will probably
trying to collect additional material
from the north american model species we
have four different species in North
America I'm going to continue trying to
apply the GPS marker for the malleus and
also torture genome analysis probably
more tray Association analysis and also
probably put potentially illegal mining
for a lot of malice and also the white
malice and torture material we have also
we cooperating with with a lot of
different people will continue on
evaluation about a lot of wild material
of the malleus also the virus material
based on those evaluation result we
don't try to select some of the material
to be including our permanent collection
in the next five years some of the
long-term goal we have for the corner
collect
first of all we hope what we can carry
out genetic study among our gene bank
together with gene banking other
countries I hope that will lead to
future exchange our material in the
future also trying to exchange an
exploration may be the wild malice and
also virus material especially in China
potentially in Turkey and other places
we would like to compete a long-term
backup storage for all the malice and
torturing and trying to develop a very
good reliable long-term backup storage
method for virus which we don't have
right now
also additional genotyping and
phenotyping of all the wild germ plasm
material we have in our collection we
like to reduce the disease level in our
field collection hopefully trying to
look into long-term trying to develop a
new strategy for long-term preservation
of the corner material we have because
we probably facing facing potential
limiting space issue also resources
issue in the future finally I want to
acknowledge II all the people involved
with the program for the last 30 years
especially group of guys I work with
every day we call them the 18 therefore
guide actually work on a collection day
in and out basically doing all the work
and also other people from the PGR you
and also former curator feel first line
professor Allan Coe plant pathology
department Larry Robertson genera CEO of
our unit and also folks at the
Kearneysville gehlbach quiz Richard from
for Colin other people are for Colin
Iqbal was the long-term choir back
backup storage and also all the folks at
PG are you and GG are you and also the
field research unit of a Cornell
University at the Geneva station
throughout the year they gave a lot of
help also all the folks at Cornell
University and finally the funding
support from the National Zoo or project
project and also the NI regional
Experimental Station funding thank you
you
the question was has Apple genome be
sequence how we in that case how I refer
to Golden Delicious how we're going to
use that yes there's a published
sequence based on Golden Delicious
that's what we use for our comparison
some of the material the GPS data we
have but I'm not expert in the area but
the discussion is because throughout the
domestication history if you simply use
Golden Delicious genome sequence as your
reference genome we do have a lot of
wild malice material that's probably not
involved with domestication of Golden
Delicious the Malus domestica de so if
you used Golden Delicious as the base
for comparison you're going to be bias
against a lot of wild material so we're
going to try to use Golden Delicious
sequence as a comparison but also we're
trying to do other comparison without
any Golden Delicious Golden Delicious
genome sequence so we're not creating
BIOS we're still working on that a lot
of other issues involve for example true
poi is a very serious issue poly poly
it's very difficult for GBS analysis
right now most of the methodology my
understanding is as the bellyful deploy
so we have we do have a lot of poly poly
material and also especially the triplet
material that can create a lot of
problem so we're still working on that
we have problem with full of sera
disease yes we do in the field we do
have a different disease that's always a
concern but it's very difficult because
it's open field collection so it's never
been clean and we don't really have a
resources to testing material all the
time so it's always a issue I do mention
that for the foreign distribution all
the material we send out have to go
through the quarantine process of the
receiving country but in the United
States at least for the malleus that's
not the case
the question is yeah the question is any
plan for mutagenesis analysis of some of
the collection there are some research
involved with for the Vitis material by
the GTR you folks they are doing some
mutation to Quine looking for certain
Milton they are looking for their some
of the material but not for malice no
yes you're right the main disease
problem we have is a fire blight
potentially of course right now we're on
chemical control but that's a very
always difficult chemical control and
also plus the pruning hopefully
potentially we can look into some other
strategy may be a cover crop for example
that's a possibility trying to hopefully
can reduce the disease level in the
orchard but it's always a balance
between how much resources we have well
how much we can do we're pretty much
stretched very thin right now for the
work we have to do so always appreciate
more health
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu